hey everybody welcome to the very first
Monday melee yeah that's right now if
you've been following us you know we
were doing things on Wednesdays we used
to call it twitch twins days but now due
to our shooting schedule of our show
we're super crazed on Wednesday so we've
started broadcasting now on Mondays you
can find us from here on out every
Monday from noon to 1:30 Pacific time
cuz we're on the west coast and we are
also on here at twitch twitch.tv slash
Team Coco and you can also find us now
on YouTube youtube.com slash Team Coco
so that's right we are bright watch this
magic trick watch look at that that's
right we're in two places now two places
so with us as always is Beth Morosky in
the chat room with you guys on the ones
and to Steven Smith hand-in-hand in
frame killed it and back there the
creeper Jason O'Malley I could just see
his legs all right what do you guys
think of my t-shirt today right there's
my douchey t-shirt pretty great today we
are gonna be continuing the saga we
started last week with blood-borne this
game worst ragequit ever I had in the
moments before we went live where I
wanted to get us past the level that we
stopped at last week so I was really
honestly 100% trying very hard to beat
this level and I died and it was
terrible and I had to get up and
actually like do a lap I was so pissed
off it was absolutely horrible but but
yeah so we're gonna and I'm gonna
actually we're gonna try to get further
this week I know we do a lot of we do we
do make a lot of yucks here a lot of
jokes a lot of yolks but this week we're
actually gonna try to actually go far
hey virtue antics hey Scotland what's up
Scotland
who's Scotland I enjoy your libations
that you make also known as Scotch but
do you want to talk a little bit about
your Scotch experience this weekend
oh I just cost on me it was great it oh
and I felt very sick on Saturday I
thought this will help and I downed like
a full tumbler of single malt scotch
thank you very much to help burn out my
sore throat I don't think it worked
great that's cool
I feel like that kind of never works so
here's where I died last time I got
pretty far but where I died right before
the stream started and I've lost my mind
because I tried to fight those two
[ __ ] dogs that's right I said it
they're [ __ ] so the question is oh I
might not have a choice so I try to
fight them again I only have one blood
vial what do we think should I try to
fight them again or should I just say
screw it and go for this big guy over
here this is on ps4 yes for playing the
ps4 version and by the way I'm gonna
need all your guys's help sir we have 13
hey alley cat what's up testicle shaped
pair bear don't you did not want to have
sex in person I smell like old cheese
and not like expensable cheese like
cheese that's been sitting out like
American cheese cheese slices oh by the
way I got two used to be very exciting
last week spent Thursday at the Playboy
Mansion that's right they invited
playboy was nice enough to invite me to
play video games of playmates which was
pretty much the greatest thing that's
ever happened to me my whole life
and it was super fun for their web
series gamer next door which is going to
be I'm not sure when it's gonna be
released but I'll let you guys know it
was fantastic I will now be taking
questions about the Playboy Mansion if
you'd like alright I guess I just gotta
go fight this guy right I'm nervous
no one else is watching I guess I gotta
go do it yeah a zero jelly been working
out that's right look at these muscles
they're fake this is a suit that they
gave me
all right I'm just gonna go for him a
little nervous so I run past this guy
should I actually fight him
oh hey YouTube what's up
Krissy oh man Oh God blood vial blood
file it up we blood file it up why I'm
I'm on the wrong guy I'm on the wrong
guy oh Jesus Christ
camera gotta help me out here Kim Jesus
never know please
okay well
we have the YouTube chat alright awesome
this is great licking wildly hey Ryan
Mitchell what's up I need to see right
bish I went to college with nope so that
would be awesome
why is cutting a girl you people in the
youtubes we're asking why we're not
using twitch to stream games we are
using Twitter stream games we're doing
both didn't you see my cool magic trick
this is twitch this is YouTube now we're
that same I thought that was a good
trick I thought it's a good trick ah
exactly where's the jacket Beth people
want to know where the jack he beefed u
bar del a exactly thanks Dylan Wilde you
guys Rock awesome hey from Malaysia hey
Geoffrey what's up thank you for joining
us
alright let's return to hunters dream
we're gonna buy some stuff I think okay
oh we played a couple games we played
mercenary Kings which is fun we played
Resident Evil Revelations which is great
and we play mario karts which is awesome
but yes absolutely check out their their
web series I think it's going on now
it's called gamer next door Pamela
Horton Amelia Talan and Raquel Compline
are they being lovely ladies I met and
hung out with and they are hilarious and
talented and oops oh my god did I just
kill the dude I was supposed to buy
stuff from
here we go four to five weapon this is
what we want great great
I can't do anything without any blood
stones awesome cool really excited
memory alter or the beef camp is if you
came on we're testing to be people on
YouTube yeah we call it getting beef
where's the who knows what the thing is
where's the beef where's the beef yeah
got getting beat YouTube when you get
killed or you kill someone else you beef
someone or you get beefed and that's
that's what it is
I kind of want some people from the
twitch stream to go over to the the
YouTube stream and educate these people
cuz on Twitch we were community you know
we're all friends here we play we play
battlefield hardline together all these
things but VI YouTube you guys are brand
new so welcome
that's right where's the beef I know
rising seven I'm looking for that
they're looking for the beef we have a
beef sign that I don't know where it is
as well as the team as well as a Conan
hit someone always move seats which is
weird every week alright well we don't
have anything we're gonna come back here
though I'm gonna remember to do this
yeah beef squad no place to awaken
fantastic no place to awaken excellent
really excited okay I guess I gotta go
here man yarn him headstone
I love like no idea I guess I gotta find
some stuff I haven't even passed the
tutorial that's the saddest part oh my
god alright hey Happy Easter Bert Allah
thank you yeah you're right
thanks misery 503 you got to collect
enough that goes together starter outfit
all right what is this nerd crap
somebody said the nerd crap is it video
games you're watching you're watching it
hey Jason
hello Jason Rock good to see you I know
this is actually this is actually for
the ps4 we're playing but we play both
ps4 and Xbox one just this this week
we're playing that I love it a cleric
beast
Thank You allottee hey Norway what's up
that's right all right okay so I think
I'm just gonna kill a bunch of guys and
get a bunch of blood stuff then come
back and buy some stuff so let's go
kills take my threaded cane dick looking
for dudes yeah you don't need teeth
teeth are so overrated you guys
seriously what's the last time you used
it yeah okay okay all right I get it I
get it
oh we're tough don't you comp these
stairs see how tough you are on the
stairs
oh not so tough of the stairs hey now
I'm dead
this game is the bait if I exist there
why do we decide this is the game we're
playing by the way this game is great I
would definitely get this game it's just
taking years off my life oh man
damn it got off the stairs Dark Souls 2
is way harder that seems impossible
what's the hardest game I'll tell you
what the hardest game I've ever played
no way et for Atari hardest game ever
that game is so hard hey you can't
figure out what you're doing I don't
know it's by the way that's on the list
of like the worst games of all time it
is the absolute worst
huge said now we're not gonna play Mario
partlet and Mario Party later
unfortunately but maybe we will
eventually we can't not this week this
week I just this week I just want to get
past this level of blow point that's all
I want that's all I wanted like that's
all I want
do be get blood echo here's a question
for the room do to get blood echoes by
killing everybody or just the big guys
anybody know this guy's my favorite you
just gotta like using a rotten wood Oh
crikey governor let me hit you with my
wood oh please cheerio
pip-pip top drawer top drawer oh Jesus
all right oh good party okay got it I'm
on fire
yeah blood echoes retreat [ __ ] hold
on let me just kill this dude okay
what's this what's this go what's going
on here it's no cuz it no cuz that guy's
got a different thing than I have
Oh someone else online dude I'm not like
all right we're going back going back
and buying [ __ ] cannot wait I love my
little half Cape go sporty I am in this
half Cape just jogging along there's no
sexy women in this game because I think
I do pretty well is our scheme ever
rock-paper-scissors that's true what do
you pick first all right let's just see
right one two three
you would four times you were like one
two three four okay more like a quarter
Cape yeah I guess you're right
it's like a quarter well no it's a half
Cape man it's coming down to his elbows
here's this case this guy's bad dude
let's talk to him yeah I am incredibly
bad at the game yeah you too yeah I'm
looking at both streams right now both
chat rooms and YouTube is like you guys
are animals
it's like chaos over there it's like
prison rules a lot of caps I you suck as
bad as Kona's haircut kill him oh my god
good lord why is your hair white my hair
went white when I was 14 genetics yeah
yeah they like fat me more everybody
nobody likes fat me more except Delta of
the people original taco all right 45
weapon here we go all right can't do
anything perfect let's do the threaded
cane more blood stuff that's great yeah
they are hardcore what repair weapons oh
here we go
okay all right great we repaired our
thing cool that's all we can do that's
all that's gonna help us
oMFG okay all right
that's all we got can i buy some more
vials at least in here somewhere
old man can you help me with these
bodies file situation press X to pay
respects
YouTube is crazy right YouTube y'all
need to settle down for for real for
real guys got to check yourself before
you wreck yourself
hashtag people would guy look at the
bass messenger that's me in a sauna by
the way here we go this is what I want
purchase items alright here we go this
is what I'm looking for
alright attire so
all right so we've what do you guys
think should we buy guys help me out
here do I want to buy the clothes
because it'll help me it'll help me with
damage right that's better than buying
blood vials and stuff don't you think
damage reduction I think that's what we
want here
these look the trousers look the best to
me I'm going trousers yep
do it do I use the trousers when I die
better not lose my mind
all right thanks pal but you could say
it's the first time I've bought
something from a skeleton in the bath
but damage reduction really all right
yeah you're Joffrey and YouTube yes we
named our guy Mark Cuban last week yeah
and that'sthat's the chatter in bling
you guys should blame yourselves buy
some balls trousers got the Sun bar jela
I just talked to stone upstairs she
actually gave me some pens which are up
there genuine so depends that's right oh
you know I'm gonna get him yep just got
these pens from soda pretty pretty
exciting sure you take him out that's
right so depends I'm gonna make it rain
so depends you ready
okay you know we don't need your circuit
anyone find the code the beef thing
where's the beef anyone find it all
right here we go I got my new trousers
look at these spiffy trousers let's get
up close in those trousers yeah a lot of
room in the crotch a lot of room in the
crotch which I guess isn't actually a
positive thing okay I think we're gonna
do the same thing I'm gonna try to
murder a bunch of suckas sucker MCs and
maybe buy some more stuff okay granted
but we're all agreed
I agree thank you
oh yeah don't swear guys yeah Beth loves
the banhammer she'll bring down the band
hammer on any fools who try to step yeah
come correct I'm trying to stab me
through the grade a oh my god I'm
already getting sick
thanks I love that you were like should
we stab this guy and we'll just keep
moving all right great
I should kill these guys though right
that's this is our goal we're killing
all these suckers whip activate
ah come on
cheater got in a couple hits though
didn't you
good I see all right
here's this a-hole who always jumps out
of me come on I see you there I see you
I can see ya I what did I say
ah hate you God did a billion I hate
this game I hate this game
I'm sorry making it rain tens I'm so
angry okay you know the other thing I
think they made the load screens in this
game really long on purpose literally I
think it's a mind trick it's such a
powerful machine it doesn't take this
long to load this game this isn't like a
Skyrim no man's sky type world this is a
tiny world it's not saying you did this
on purpose blood-borne and well played
by the way just this whole game is to
make you angry to make me personally
angry alright I was trying I was every
five hundred I was gonna go back but
apparently I can't stay alive long
enough to get 500 blood stones or hearth
stones or touch stones or what mood
rings or whatever the eff these things I
need to get to get better trousers and
by the way can I just buy a normal long
cape do I have to run around this dumb
looking half cape
and it's Monday
and pick up your axe stop dragging your
axe on the ground like a dumbass come on
upstairs oh there's this guy forgot my
[Music]
I'm gonna use a vial or what we're just
gonna keep running here can I please use
a file love use a vial thank you no no
big deal just fighting for my life here
against a bunch of geared ghouls is it
the whip supposed to hit more than one
person at a time guy oh my god man
are you dead oh I didn't equip my good
pants yet ah I still got my pants on no
that's probably you thanks guys
uh I gotta quit my pants of course just
like in real life
you got to equip your pants I didn't
even have my right pants I still got the
dumb foreign trousers there we go
cook those pants pants it quit hashtag
equip your pants pull your pants up look
how look he's checking his pants he's
actually pulling his pants up hashtag
ooh my butt looks good in these jeans
yeah nice a good cut okay I only got
that only got me 288 by the way
we're going back here is this a good
idea no because this is where the big
bag is okay
no suspenders height yeah dead booty
that booty is tight hey Finland what's
up sheeple wow that that YouTube every
time I look over at the YouTube chat you
guys are serious
no I didn't die I quit my pants though
chatroom told me pull your pants up I'm
gonna use the blunderbuss more I haven't
really been using it god I really hate
that guy man every time
blood echoes alright I'm going back now
I'm going back this is where he made our
mistake before yeah if there's a guy up
here too I can kill oh Jesus Christ
guys sneaky so sneaky all right I got so
many I can't die now man I got to go
back oh how do I get back up there Oh
remember the five DS of dodging Kenson
900 what are the five DS of dodging
dodge dodge dodge dodge dodge okay let's
just be a little sneaky here I don't
think I want to fight these guys
oh great he may look awesome
yeah I know oh [ __ ] I can't go up here
cuz I drop down
this could get a little gnarly
which I kill these guys are sweet from
the pass or what the sky rainy season
come on come on up here let's dance baby
get up here let's dance come on come on
come on take your time the camera in
this is a little oh my god are you
kidding me
you've never done that move before in
your life never oh I got a blow pop oh
yeah sweetie right there there's a G
right there okay just come on up here oh
my god
there we go great great all right
another dude come on man
yeah yeah I need to figure out a better
strategy here another blood vial that's
good all right I'm just I'm literally
just trying to get back to where I was
back to the hunters dream this way watch
those giant dogs up here don't kill
everybody here
your friend from what I did I get
murdered immediately the big fat guy
with the axe fat axe man I call it
oh really okay regular original and
usually nice YouTube here we go alright
turn 200 feet guys I like it we're being
smart about stuff Kevin 322 at 320
second well done
YouTube he's crazy yeah great Dino
ranked bot 911 you're exactly right Ron
is the new strategy and so far the new
strategies working out like a charm
you know what let's look on the bright
side here wait I don't want to do this I
want to go down and buy new stuff from
our from Batman you know a little bad
girl hey bad girl what's up girl you
looking fine alright let's figure this
out actually get some more blood vials
yeah right yes don't we think how many
one two let's see what weapons I can
find first okay no weapons but we can't
get more she ate Algarve let's get the
garb feeling good about this garb a lot
of people said they're blinking bleh
yeah well I can't see you it's the
internet so garb got been that's all we
need here's the problem I don't have any
blood vials if I die am I gonna lose it
all my garb that can't they this game
would not be that mean oh dude this
almost doubles my shite
oh look at this woo hey it's like I'm
gonna sass its Creed I like it you can't
live that way
in a boat you can only buy weapons that
you feel other hunters who wield got it
okay makes sense yeah perfect don't
worry about the vials you'll get them as
you go through thank you
hashtag Mark Cuban I'm feeling it
Conan's not being kept hostage Conan has
a show to do
he's very busy yell eat he always might
stop by although today I think he did a
CNN interview where he's doing one right
now so he's a busy guy he's a busy guy
but you know it you know we got instead
of counting pens hashtag pen rain
hashtag pen 15 all right here we go all
right now should we move on guys or
should we buy some more stuff what do we
think is our strategies obviously
working here this is like Groundhog Day
by the way saw it follows great very
many great movie what do you think
everyone should go everyone in the chat
you go see it follows great movie it's
real fun
see if you've seen it follows yet
turn around at the lamp a down the
ladder can I oughta graph one of those
pens I don't know it's really hard to
write on one of these pens I think
although they got a good nib you guys
want to see the nib on this pen you
measure every if you know you can't
judge a book by its cover but you can
judge in pen bite snip look at that nib
that's a great day all right
hashtag nib life it's only gonna be
Mondays 12:00 to 1:30 let us clean these
foul streets yes Hey ladies
not like fire how much oh no I used the
file before you go the thing is this
game would be way easy wait so I'm gonna
go take the shortcut by the big guy
right yes who's saying that
lock on I know I know I'll target I'll
target I promise I'll target next time
someone on YouTube said that YouTube
this is this is your chance to redeem
yourselves built the animals I'm gonna
try to go past this guy without fighting
him another good job buzzer you got it
if this doesn't work YouTube you and I
are gonna have some words that is a big
axe there is no reason to have that
large of an axe
so what do we think we think we go over
there and I just dodge around him I
don't think you could have come out here
though now twitches they don't trust
YouTube there's nothing I know we're
plane switching here we go sir cops here
comes oh he does to be fair it did just
say nothing but giant foes here see he's
not gonna come out he's not gonna come
out here come on out Nancy hey there hey
oh wait I take it back you know what I
think holy jesus Christ
can't jump that high there's no way that
guy could jump like that
what the hell and then 90 minute load
screen well I don't I don't that's in
pop that's insane
holy crap trusting YouTube is like
asking six-year-old nice for real estate
Oh
hashtag blames to even be wrecked I got
totally beef where's that can you find
that sign I got super beefed that was
awful man that guy jumped like 50 feet
he's got major hops that's crazy town
all right good news is we still got our
dope club you're still looking so fresh
so clean I think I'm gonna try that one
more time let's just try let's try
getting this sucker maybe from the fire
please
okay done and done these guys are
[ __ ]
we've dicket's to pass don't try man
everyone's like scared for me yeah I
love it
oh man it's no use now pieces of tofu
I love backseat gaming you should tell
me what to do I'm not I'm not joking
like I want to know what to do here
I enjoy your everyone's backseat gaming
oh really
I missed him with the blunderbuss I'm on
fire oh please I'm sorry guys that was
just
oh man oh my god both gotta head in the
bonfire yeah exactly
there's a lever to the left of the giant
gate all right so when I run in there
I'm gonna if I can avoid the giant fat
guy Marlon Brando with an axe basically
fan of joy get out of Marlon Brando's
way go to the left all right grab a
blender you have to kill that guy to
have a chance the crazy shortcut Oh
kill them all dead that's my backseat
gaming tip all right I'll give it a shot
man although I think that it's gonna be
tough I don't need to fight him I can't
tell people are serious or not about the
fight so I'm not gonna fight him because
I'll die
it's just an alley with a quiz at the
end beware of that guy honey I want to
get stuff where I go or I go forward
like hey look I got this guy hey come on
pal yeah all right I'll just go for it
I'm trying to kill people all right I'm
just gonna go do you run run run nope
whoops
oh wait that guy's got blood echoes
though do I want those blood echoes
[Applause]
crazy in here all right dude you're
blocking me
Steamies now
Wow okay good job Undertaker alright I'm
just gonna run through everything let's
just run let's run should we run let's
run yes it's been two weeks on the same
level Steven Smith captain positivity
this hashtag hates his life that's what
it is
hashtag miserable mofo alright blame the
hashtag blame the undertaking rekt the
role is real for sure ten deaths shirt
comes off I should have started with my
shirt off if that's the case good lord
you guys aren't ready for this
underneath here it's like it's a lot of
rashes and then they've got like a I've
got a sweet Carly Rae Jepsen tattoo just
right here Jepson my own it's time to
pocket and thug life is just as chips in
life
there we go speed run let's just do it
nope
see you later hey cleaver man you know I
think in this town I mean oh if you open
a cleaver story you would be like the
richest dude ever
everyone's got cleavers and knives for
my speedruns
Wow I run in to seek out whoa dude come
on me no one can catch me at my
medium-paced jog
oh no whoops whoops run button run
button please stop checking your bun oh
great
it's under the couch is the thing back
this thing under two popsicle stick you
grab it that's what happened to me what
do you think Conan I don't know you're
pretty terrible thanks boss
shameful shameful oh yeah hey YouTube
hey cutter might stop by best impression
by the way in real life he sounds
exactly like that just you although I
think it's important that you know now
because then it'll be less less
surprising with you medium
I'm just running right we just think I'm
running we just gotta get past this part
we're all singing this part I'm sick of
this part you're sick of it
we're all sick of it everyone is sick of
it even though this guy's blood it goes
I guess the blood echoes are just kind
of random
[Applause]
I know YouTube just like what happened
you watch the street yeah that's true
I welcome it I'll hold the circle sprint
thank you thank you that's what I water
great exactly what I needed
backing away from these dogs oh this is
great hey doggy Oh nope not going down
there
a gym I hit scary guy stairs miss me
whoops okay okay okay okay okay all
right all right okay yeah oh hello
pardon me how can I just run past this
guy I'm doing it see it wait a second
I've just got to get to that next dream
situation
oh my god holy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] oh my god
what is going on come on man come on
[Applause]
[Music]
no [ __ ]
no [ __ ] oh my god it's like a giant
hairball that's the scariest hairball
I've ever seen
good job stupid you really screwed up oh
well the good news is there's a lady
over here hi hey certainly are hey whoa
what I try to share my cool t-shirt I
shot her in the face sorry
hello I am and all here in this dream to
look after you okay
honorable hunter pursue the echoes of
blood
and I will channel them into your
strength
yeah where were you the first 90 times I
was playing this level
[Music]
alright let's channel blood echoes very
well let the echoes become your strength
let me stand close Oh guys wait you guys
might want to close your eyes for this
powe that is gonna be sexy time
there's nothing less sexy than this
screen we're looking at right now I
thought I thought things are gonna be
like you know this is like of course
this is best like porn
this is hashtag best porn it's all this
alright strength right strength is what
we want I don't have any so right now I
have no blood echoes Mark Cuban's a
little low in the old blood echoes yeah
I did I can't
I don't have any
well this sucks okay well great okay
what
oh my god
I just looked over at the YouTube chat
for a second and it just said in all
caps all goons banned to hell I thought
I said I said I'm not good at playing
games only banning all right I don't
know what's happening here
I can't channel any blood echoes don't
have any blood echoes farewell good but
I guess when I come back here now you
find your worth in the waking world well
I I did lose my half cape and traded it
in for a skirt so that's great really
excited about that
okay you know you could just start start
your boy with the thing where you could
channel the blood echoes I don't need to
get to the end and then have to go all
the way back you know and just start
your boy at the blood echo part no no
again at the end of the game end of the
first level this is the worst yeah
exactly Dexter Morgan I'm sorry I'm
gonna show you we're gonna get we are
going to get to the second level today
it is gonna happen I can't promise you
but I'm just wrong we I feel strongly
about this I
all right it's like insane I can't even
do it I can't even deal with what's
going on to the YouTube guys if you guys
are the twitch chat you should just go
over to YouTube for a second just to see
what's going on just not stuff is
bananas just what is happening over
there can you figure it out
alright I'm gonna try to get some blood
guys just to see what she meant by I'm
Ali
creepers back FG and OC is no because
after does it I was at the YouTube
channel off of youtube savages
I'm sorry YouTube you guys gotta behave
yourself channel your blood farts that's
what somebody said baby jet channel your
blood parts
well everybody okay that guy needs to be
based ok YouTube's a stop writing in all
caps we get it oh my god I can't even
handle it I'm just gonna stare into the
fire they'll look at this this guy has
seen that our guy has seen the YouTube
chat just like just looking at the
flames like YouTube watching where yeah
some people just wanna walks to air burn
yeah let's all go down to the cleaver
store and get more cleavers good idea
how am i doing a speedrun again what's
four no this time I'm killing people for
at gos yeah
I'm killing folks for right guys I think
becomes you boy
oh yeah
Vienna Jones in this [ __ ] my just lure
some of us back here honestly
here comes 20 dudes shall we till they
spread out you think
yeah boy oh no they don't feed us at
lorem watch out for the shields you
might just shut down the YouTube yeah
guys can't behave yourselves to shut you
down man I don't care human life means
nothing look at what I'm wearing
he's
all right though well pretty happy
looking good feeling good really use a
guy with blood echoes all right here's
the guy's gonna jump out at us I I can
see I see you there
I see I see you does he know blood
echoes everyone goes to hide kill this
guy
you guys come up from behind right
nine dying dying dying dying dying dying
back up back up one of us though
for the door in the house you ran
through oh okay
there's a door straight ahead I see so
that's the lamp that's the lantern I'm
missing the lantern that's why this is
so hard because then thank you so much
that's very helpful
wait so I've been missing the second
lantern there is actually another
checkpoint in this level
know what I'm gonna do right now is go
back where I was before and spend all
this money because I might die because I
have to go through all the stuff I was
at I have to go through all those guys
still which is not gonna oh no second
Lantern I think I should go should I
kill these two
what should I do here should I press
forward I only have one vial there's a
guy up there he might have a file
[Music]
no vial ah shouldn't kill you twice
alright so here we go let's go let's mix
it up let's get in here right I'm gonna
run through all speed run through these
guys pest the press X to pay respects
yes ferret who likes pecan I do like
pecan pie alright I'm gonna run through
these guys who actually there nothing
man
let's kill this dude up here miss me
it's me
you know what I'm not gonna fight I'm
not fighting we're running
we're running we're running we're
running a whole dogs hey puppy yeah yeah
all right I kind of want to go back now
honestly let's spend this money is that
crazy how do I get back up there I don't
know if I can there's a dog over here
yeah not so tough when you can't take me
about surprise eggs when you talk to
people inside
cup of sugar I can't this the only other
thing to do grow man
well go ahead and stuff it I know how
your tricks all right well I'm just
gonna wreck your barrels yep that's
right hey there's some good dog meat out
here if you're hungry
good dog meat I'm gonna destroy yep
Puppy Bowl blood Dew do the dew cold
blood how do I get back straight yeah
I'm going I can't go back please for the
love of God go back to the house and
open the door this house this house
oh I haven't been in here before I'm
really scared actually open the door
first
no yeah they'll say no they're all
saying don't go down they're all saying
don't go down here okay okay okay okay
go back to the house and open the word
this house oh yeah yeah yeah go back to
that house okay okay so that's up here
yeah I went across the division I'm
going back to that I'm going go into the
house
and whoever designed the city bad job
very confusing great for video getting
terrible I'm going here I'm going to the
house here we go
bad guy another dude in here two blood
files there we go
that's mean there's something terrible
about to happen this door this door this
door is this the door you're talking
about oh it's just a shortcut
so now that doors open and now you can
go oh great well look at those giant
guys down there oh my god
not going down that way oh I see I see I
see
wait so now oh I can go back to the
dream this way is that the idea
oh I get it this is the gate this is the
very beginning so smart you guys are so
smart oh my god either you're super
smart or you just googled all that and
really wanted to not see this level
again yes guys thank you chattering
Thank You Chapman
meanwhile on the YouTube chat scrotum
fantastic Coco what's your name oh hey
guys I'm bleh this is Beth Morosky she's
handling the chat Steven Smith over here
on the ones and twos and creeper in the
back Jason O'Malley
oh wait I do have any blood echoes I can
channel into health they're channeling
my blood I guess the echoes become your
strength okay keep it down to it no true
selected I can't
I see I boosted
oh I only got one blood I go alright
great
confirm
829 black has a level up do we want to
level up we do right by Tov eyetality
for more health as what people are
saying by talent vitality alright
vitality and skill
well vitality is lower I'm going
vitality skill vitality
okay I'm gonna vitality oh man alright
gotta get that gotta get that vitality
you know then we'll spend the rest of
our can't buy [ __ ]
yeah
all right I feel like we're actually
making some progress in this game thanks
to you guys thank you for your help
alright now we're gonna use the shortcut
that we unlocked I do like your shortcut
me to Conan thanks a lot that's right
we're gonna get out of this level yet
you guys we're gonna get out of this
level yet we can do it did you do for
extract this mm-hmm
oh yeah what what death count are we on
I think we've died five times I think Oh
No oh we're up to 15 I think I've died
five times this time this time wait this
time I've died ten times yeah
man oh look at this this is great guys
she changed my world with a shortcut
situation here we go oh just so casually
lights me on fire like have some fire
flaming thirteen oh my god you did leave
for a minute although I said I didn't
die - here we go back into the house
everywhere everyone's still alive
anybody else back here any wants of
death wheelchair guy uh Professor X you
want some death thanks
here we go let's go upstairs
I see you I see you right there I can
see you forget it we're going up here
can ambushed by this idiot find the dick
take a threaded cane to your cane all
right two big scary monsters or one big
scary monster and some crows two big
ones
non-stop stops does back judge back that
back please dot Jesus Christ dodge back
John for the love of Christ use a blood
ba use a blood by using blood ball use a
blood ball using football you know Jesus
quote they're easy to kill unquote
Stephen Smith 2015 yeah dog Jimmy wait
back on camera though that's better
man go get the items on the stairs you
say oh that's a smart idea
alright beef got beef YouTube oh hold r2
for a charge Oh r2 for a charge attack
yay where's that beef cam it rq-4
charged attack I do like them charged
attacks are - all right here we go next
time we beef I think we know
you guys know what happens when you hit
15 deaths right beef cam comes out there
we go alright down here whoa that's cool
that'll be a fun sneak attack situation
all right into the house with this guy
yeah yeah yeah I wait in the dark what a
creep just like hanging out in the dark
there like a creep Oh Professor X in the
corner I know professor or do like you
skew there we go stairs okay how much
less scary with this game be oh come on
really
you swing it up buddy cuz I'm over here
alright what is it like barenaked ladies
like constantly was on a loop like it's
been one week if you elected me john
mutant dogs are scary to walk up to
these guys blunder possums
okay and there are two while they're
like recovery
I have molotovs okay well they're coming
okay dudes I'm right back by the house
oh and you can are too I love things
like
but - he actually does
oh boy
oh I see oh I can see the charge attack
only works with the brush attack yeah
kind of wish you didn't need all those
doughnuts it can't get through the door
awesome alright now we go back I think
and spend some of these echoes right
don't we think we go back I think
there's a dude back here
this game was about smashing barrels I
would be the best alright wait I'm going
back to yeah great idea no dude I got
970 I'm gonna go back and charge up
quick get some of those gloves or
something
how'd you think I know well I want to
look fresh maybe there's somebody over
here I can just kill to get at that no I
can I can up my vitality what's over
here yeah definitely going back down
that's the day that's what those dogs or
guarding
wait let me just go back I just want to
go back
because I want to go back to this house
over here the best thing I've ever
learned about anything
whoa go by and it sends the you will
give you a badge it's helpful you can
you can sell your old go behind I can't
what's the yharnam sting hey Anna and
three and YouTube this game is called
blood warm playing flow board for ps4
today it's extremely difficult but
really fun I'm having some fun it's
pretty exciting
welcome home okay why would I every time
I talk to you I want a channel blood
that goes why I don't care about your
life story I don't care I don't care oh
yeah
vitality again her skill now they're
saying vitality skill damn oh man we are
leveling up right and left come over
here alright I'm gonna try to fight this
big guy
how do I use my molotovs anyway man yeah
central yharnam slanter do we feel bad
standing by a fence by the sewers talk
to her by the Kirk hammer when you can
alright pick up the bell zombie goats
yes we know the old PC console thing we
know we know we get it 2015 console for
PC would get it guys thank you again for
joining us just to reiterate Monday
melee is the new twitch 20 we will be
streaming every Monday 12:00 to 1:30
Pacific time both on twitch.tv slash
Team Coco and youtube.com slash team
Chicago here we go Gilbert love the name
Gilbert I love it oh man please give me
the oh dude you can give me a badge
we're gonna be in school while you do
this to us our rice boy well you can
also look at all past broadcasts on
twitch TV to chat to church and healing
Church that's what we're going to get to
church
I call it Taco Bell
Arby's also I've been out a big Arby's
cave lately guys delicious Oh
roast beef
let's curly fries hell yeah I love that
French dip by the way uh quick tip for
all your high fibers out there don't do
what I just didn't hold your hand in
front of your face cuz if you missed you
could smack do give me this bad bro yes
master ninja we do that's true we do get
paid to do this blue Arby's what booze
RVs this is great all right well this
guy didn't give me anything so I didn't
get a badge
no badge I don't know I don't know to
say oh great alright well so never then
this guy's like the needlenose Ned of
this watch that first step it's a doozy
here we go back into the house creeper
on the right I really like that movie
edge of tomorrow because I'm such a
video game thing haven't seen it great
movie like playing video games great
great movie real fun
it's basically Groundhog Day sci-fi
action
alright so hey governor good eye good
eye shrimp on the barbie
this is a knife is that is that Boston
that Boston all right we're gonna kill
the big dogs I know you wicked smack oh
oh right oh yeah knows that's not me
though is it so what of guys is that
what it's fast
[Applause]
hey puppy
give my boy it's based on a comic okay
Oh God oh my god get me out of here oh
my god I'm trapped Jesus God no never
talked to me about edge of tomorrow when
I'm fighting giant mutant dogs never
what do I we have this discussion every
week I can't remember I think it was the
beef beef cam 15 deaths or I can just
skip the werewolves somebody said yeah
yeah thanks for tip boot camp oh my god
yes exactly
kill this guy quick murder this dude all
right now we're just gonna go try to
kill this team oh not that way into the
house all right I don't care about you
although you know what I should kill you
though because otherwise you're just
gonna try to kill me right kill you and
I'll kill you know what the deal is here
all right so how do we use our Molotov
cocktail anybody remember
thank you
shouldn't I just run past this guy and
fight the big tree man am I gonna
I think the key here is take out the
birds first right
I mean the house yeah the owl's what is
beYOU know those keep popping up no
mercy for beasts hunting we say what I
say fine
this note is a fine
Jesus Christ what Jesus on top
you think so this wasn't here before
I'm unhappy
I'm supposed to be
camera is killing me
[Applause]
see anything
yeah thanks man
my controller so sweaty right
so maybe I wait for it to jump and I go
behind it
[Applause]
she's not it keeps like on checking
okay this is the bad
oh my god camera camera camera what
board seriously work on your camera
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
jump jump
working
jump
dick please jump
oh that's bad
don't used to parry when you [ __ ] the
right time go for his weakness oh man
that was awful
well I think that'll probably do it for
this week
sorry to say kids but thank you for
joining us for the very first melee
Monday we hope you guys had a great time
please tweet at us at Team Coco hashtag
melee Monday to let us know what games
you want to see here on the stream hello
to YouTube thank you for joining us this
week we hope you guys had a great time
we'll be streaming again every week on
both twitch and YouTube and for barosky
Steven Smith Jason O'Malley myself we'll
see you guys next week see you later bud